I want to start today with something a
little different and and very interesting
and important in understanding a lot of the
structures that have gotten the politics of
the United States to where they are today.
We're going to look at a new poll from The
New York Times, from New York Times with
Siena College. And it's not about who's
winning Biden or Trump. It's really about one
of the fundamental inequalities that we have
in the United States. It's not income inequality,
which we'll talk about later today with our guest.
It is a poll that confirms something I've been
talking about for many years, which is that on
the issues, the United States electorate, meaning
people, you, me, us, we are well to the left
compared to number one, what many people might
assume is the left right balance of the country.
But maybe more importantly, the country is to the
left of where our elected representatives are. Our
elected representatives are far more conservative
than the makeup of the United States. We have a
country where if you go to individual people
and you ask them about policy, very important.
You ask about policy issues, policy questions.
You come away with the impression that the
country is quite, quite left, certainly more
left than many people are willing to admit.
But then you look at governors and you look
at state legislatures and you look at the
makeup of the Senate and the makeup of corporate
media. And it's sort of seems like a center right
country. But as I've told you before, we have
three to four different systems in this country
that keep our representation well to the right
of the actual electorate. So let's not get ahead
of ourselves. Let's go through it in pieces. This
is one of those types of stories which, you know,
it doesn't it's not a click bait story. It's not
going to get 500000 views on YouTube. But if you
don't understand this, you miss a lot of why the
country is the way it is. So it's really important
to do. First and foremost, the New York Times
poll asked likely voters about their positions
on a variety of issues. And when you look at
the numbers, there is nothing center right
about this country. For example, 72 percent of
the country wants a second two trillion dollar.
KORONA My current corona virus stimulus package,
72 percent. Only 21 percent oppose a second corona
virus stimulus in a country this polarized and
seemingly divided. Seventy two percent agreement
on anything is stunning. 72 percent want the
two trillion second stimulus. How about this?
67 percent of the country believes there should be
a public health insurance option. Now, I know it's
not single payer. It's not Medicare for all.
But remember when the debate started in 2010,
2009 about the Affordable Care Act or Obamacare,
President Obama started the negotiation at me.
Know, I'd like a public option. The Republican
Party went crazy pretending it was some kind of
socialist government takeover of health care. And
yet 67 percent of this country agrees we should
we should have it. When you hear Trump talk
about we're going to get rid of Obamacare at
rallies and his crowd cheers and Fox News talks
about it in less than glowing terms, you might
get the impression that there's a lot of debate
among the public, but 67 percent of the country
agrees. This assumption, something we should have
something seem is something this controversial
with hundreds of millions of dollars spent
in opposition and two thirds of the country
flat out says we should have we should have this
option. There should be such a government option.
Now it gets more interesting. Joe
Biden's two trillion dollar climate plan,
which Donald Trump and Republicans present pretend
is crazy. They say it'll end the auto industry.
They say it'll end fossil fuel industry.
They say it's outrageous. It's socialist.
Sixty six percent of the country supports
Joe Biden's two trillion dollar climate plan,
which includes getting back into the Paris climate
accords. Some elements using the Green New Deal as
a framework, phasing out fossil fuel vehicles on
and on and on. Two thirds of the country wants it,
even things that have become almost rallying cries
of the right, like their opposition to a national
MASC mandate, which, by the way, would really
be a president saying, hey, governors, please
do mask mandates in your states. And it would
ultimately be up to governors whether to do it
or not. Fifty nine percent of the country wants a
national MASC mandate. Here's another interesting
one. Fracking. Donald Trump and Republicans have
made a huge deal out of saying Joe Biden will ban
fracking. It's not actually what Biden would do.
Biden has a plan to phase it out over time. But as
if continuing to frack is so important. Trump has
been hammering, hammering, hammering Biden on that
only 44 percent of the country wants fracking
to exist. And. Almost equal amount. 42 percent
doesn't. And 14 percent isn't sure. A big portion
of that. I believe if they learn more about it,
would would be would be against fracking. So
this is not a right wing country. When you look
at this, I mean, even if you just say, let's
only look at policies with 60 percent approval
or higher, 60 percent or higher support, that
would mean we get a two trillion dollar second
coronavirus stimulus, public health insurance. And
Biden's two trillion dollar climate plan. That's
just if we set the line at 60 percent and we say
only do things where 60 percent of the country
agrees. That's three major policies. That would be
a major leftward switch. So we then must ask the
question, why does the Senate, 53 Republicans?
Why do we have 26 Republican governors? Why is
it so hard to remove a lunatic Republican
president? And as I've said before, we have
systems that favor the American right. Example
number one, Electoral College. The Electoral
College system has handed Republican wins to
Republican candidates who lost the popular vote.
Much like on the issues, the will of the people
was to elect the Democrat. The Electoral College
handed it to a Republican. That's a systemic help
to the right example. Number two, gerrymandering,
which is the strategic drawing of congressional
districts, has allowed way more Republican
members of the House than you would have with
fairly drawn districts. The Democratic Party
would have a bigger majority right
now were it not for gerrymandering.
There are previous Republican majorities,
which may have not been Republican majorities
were it not for gerrymandering, systemic help
to the American right. Example number three,
the Senate. As an institution, when you give
each state to senators and the states vary
widely in population, low population states get
disproportionately more power. California has
60, 70 times the population of Wyoming. California
has two senators. Wyoming has two senators.
Wyoming is a red state. Wyoming. Senators have
insanely more power relative to their populations
than California. Because conservatives prefer on
average to live more rurally, whereas Democrats,
left wingers, progressives prefer to live more
in urban or suburban settings at a systemic
level that gives more power to fewer right leaning
people. So the key takeaways here are not to get
tricked by really bad talking points for many
on the right, including talking points like
this is a center right country. It's
not. When you fairly poll people
on issues, you see that this is a center left to
left country. And number two, we have systemic
elements of how our system is organized that
have our representation be far to the right
of what the actual country believes
on a number of different issues.
Something to keep in mind as we go forward over
the next two weeks towards this upcoming election.